[Música]
jubilee
reunimos a siete carnívoros yo como
carne yo como carne yo como carne yo
como carne ya como carne yo como carne
yo como carne uno es vegano si el grupo
descubre quién es el impostor se
repartirán un premio en efectivo
si el impostor sobrevive ganará todo el
premio
quien es el impostor jubilee el impostor
carnívoros hola a todos
qué tipo de música les gusta
la música vegana yo tengo una pregunta
que desayunaron esta mañana que
desayunaron esta mañana tocino verdad yo
soy al leche de vaca no pero no tomó
leche de vaca es que sí porque no bebés
leche me gustan los lácteos es asqueroso
comes carne
de desayuno en el que facebook tengo una
pregunta como definen ustedes el
organismo perderme todo lo bueno es una
vez cierto estoy confundida con basado
en plantas y el veganismo puede haber
carnes que sean de origen vegetal no
estoy seguro eso creo y
es más como el
mismo es más bien un estilo de vida sí
como les gusta cocinar la cav
regalaron una freidora de aire yo me
dijo que trabaje me pareció sospechoso
porque mi madre es vegana y cocine el
tofu en la freidora de aire así que
conecte los puntos no puedo cocinar para
mis amigos porque si son veganos no sé
que darles
votos de los seguidores quién es el
impostor
[Música]
puso pocas palabras hasta su lenguaje
corporal era muy reservado
si ellos se parece a rachel berry si
alguien es vegano sería rachel berry
encantadora lo es
[Música]
y adiós a todos no sé que les dio la
impresión de que yo era vegana tal vez
ellos están pensando hipster chica
blanca es vegana porque es muy popular a
dinos otra vez por fin lo consumes
lácteos cuál es la razón de que no te
gustan pero cuál es tu argumento y no
sino una razón solo prefiero la leche de
avena en mis cafés con leche y cosas
pero no se trata de
comprar auténtica leche cuál es la razón
que te hace elegir una alternación para
ti el sabor yo creo que eso es
sospechoso
me di cuenta de que empezó a retroceder
y trataba de defenderse me encanta la
leche de avena pero no lo iba a decir
por la mala publicidad y tenía razón
yo fuera la impostora no me delataría
así no lo sé qué dices esta puede ser tu
estrategia porque yo solo digo que la
gente no necesita los lácteos incluso si
no son veganos el veganos apoyo por eso
también me gusta la leche de almendras y
la de avena deberíamos pasar a otro tema
algo como cocina en el pollo bien yo
cocino 6 muslos de pollo por ambos lados
y cocino el arroz en el caldo a fuego
lento
si me vuelven loco los muslos de pollo
antes de entrar deje algo desagradable
en el baño de aquiles
150 menos dos veces una o dos meses hice
esa pregunta porque los veganos tienen
una dieta más sana una dieta sana un
sistema digestivo más sano van más al
baño
cuántas veces a la semana comen carne
siempre es una vez para amazon no tengo
tiempo para cocinar porque me levanto
temprano todos los slas compro mi
almuerzo en fila james son me encanta
probarlo en una parrillera
y siempre hablo mucho con los chefs
sobre la carne alguien trató de ser
vegano yo soy mexicano hawaiano mi edad
no me permite ser
vegetariano yo lo intenté pero gracioso
intentaste cercana cuando fue eso sólo
duró un día fue hace años era para estar
más sana supongo pero no funcionó
tiene que ser hillary se está saltando
el guión no quiere responder a las
preguntas no le gustan los lácteos no
hay dudas ella es africana mía dijo que
intentó ser vegana por un día solo por
un día para mí sabe cómo alguien vegano
si ya estaba haciendo las preguntas pero
no respondía ninguna de ellas y ella se
fue como parece una vegana extravagante
contamos todos los votos y tenemos un
empate el empate es entre hillary y mía
tienen 30 segundos para deliberar y
elegir una persona para eliminar te
envía dijo que fue vegana porque no lo
volvería a intentar si eso es los medios
o de acuerdo contigo pero hillary no ha
respondido bien a las preguntas amigo yo
también desconfío de hillary pero podría
ser sólo un amante del pollo
[Risas]
15 idea primero
y la persona eliminada en esta ronda es
mía
lo siento mío
si todos están seguros de que ya sacaron
al impostor pueden terminar el juego
ahora pero si la mayoría tiene dudas el
juego continuará por favor levanten la
mano si quieren seguir jugando
a partir de ahora por cada vez que
expulsen a alguien que no sea el
impostor se reducirá el precio total del
dinero bien bien no haremos eso tengo
una pregunta para kyle y maui cuando
pienso en los veganos suelo asumir que
tienen la morfología delgada entonces
que hacen para estar en forma como es su
alimentación diaria
yo
soy una persona poco saludable sé que la
carne te da proteínas pero tengo un
metabolismo rápido y por eso me como
seis mozos de pollo y sólo con eso
muslos de pollo no siempre pido alitas y
también se han dicho este pollo único
que comes es carne bueno seguido a tus
palabras quién come solo muslos de pollo
y pollo siempre la sensación de
satisfacción que te produce el simple
hecho de morder un jugoso sándwich de
pollo usando este pollo de popeyes por
ejemplo es una ola de euforia es muy
orgásmico
volvamos a maui alex es vegano de
findeter
me lo dicen estas proteínas
de batidos
del pollo de la carne de batidos primero
que la carne
es más barato
y tengo una pregunta interesante sé que
los veganos están en contra de
desarrollar animales vivos están en
contra del uso de piel de animales en
general eso es cuero lo son o si estoy
segura de que lo son los míos lo son y
las tuyas no sé creo que sí
[Risas]
es de cuero real o falso no sé ni
siquiera vieron a qué temperatura
cocines acá yo cumplo la carne pre
cocida y el pollo la carne sólo la
cocina
formamos una alianza cuando acordamos
votar por mí el siguiente paso es votar
por hillary vote por kyle porque dijo
que comía 6 muslos de pollo
a seis museos todos los días no lo puedo
creer
ah
están perdiendo dinero a dios
por favor levanten la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
de acuerdo bien la mayoría quiere
terminar el juego vamos a terminar el
juego creía que las chicas fueran
veganas se tiende a creer que las
mujeres están más interesadas en la
salud de ghana y todo eso más que los
hombres y siento que los hombres quieren
sacar a las chicas somos creo que es
cailloma uy
[Risas]
si las luces se ponen verdes significa
que sacaron al impostor y ganaron si las
luces se ponen rojas significa que el
impostor sigue y pierden
no
lo sabía no puede ser los diablos en
serio no soy yo no soy yo manuel tú eres
el vegano
eres tú
si no contesto si no la revelación que
el pk no de un paso adelante y se revele
en 3 2 1
[Risas]
revelan mucho mucho sobre ustedes
sólo estaba jugando con ustedes
gracias a todos los carnívoros
gracias a avaya bridge you feel y amigos
a mi mamá ya pukki a rey rey a tyler
perry estoy buscando un trabajo gracias
a jesus el más sabio estoy feliz por
estar vivo y por ganar este dinero billy
amigos